- A friend and colleague
of mine, Mark Lytle,
was taught by John Blum and
he says Blum used to say,
"The only people that he
knew of who could write
"almost directly for galleys are Churchill
and Arthur Schlesinger."
He's a wonderfully fluent writer,
he's banging out 3,000 words a day.
And that was actually something that made
him very politically useful, as well.
Galbraith talks about how
when the two of them were
speechwriters for Stevenson
that again Schlesinger
was the person who would
walk into the Elk's club
as they were called, he
would take off his jacket,
he would sit at his desk, light a cigar,
and he would just bang
out a speech and pull
it out of the typewriter
and it was ready to go.
There was this kind of
wonderful fluency about
the way in which he wrote.